[Music]
we will begin today with
a few introductions and some of
the questions we've prepared for our
panelists from the
africa business club and europe student
club and then we will get to your
questions which i think are the most
important part
of today's session we want to make sure
that you leave this session
feeling like you've had all your
questions answered about
these two amazing organizations and our
panelists
experiences at the gsb so without
further ado let's get started
um so for student panela
could you introduce yourselves perhaps
stating your name
your year at the dsp or your hometown or
prejudice you're
moved perhaps a favorite thing about the
gsb
why don't we start with ori
hi everybody um my name is oriaka saida
but i go by ori um pre gsb
i was in los angeles
um and i am representing the african
business club i'm the cfo of the after
business club
um and one of my favorite things about
the gsb
uh it's cliche but it's the people i've
made such wonderful friends
i've met some wonderful faculty members
and
it's just a great community over here
awesome thank you um how about jacob
happy too so my name is jacob i'm
originally from germany
uh i was living in berlin prior to the
gsb
uh and i think my favorite thing about
the gsb i have to agree with with orion
that
um i think the the moment i really
realized it was i was in europe over the
summer and kind of one or two weeks out
i already missed being here
missed the people um and i was really
looking forward to coming back and i
think having that feeling after only
being here for a year is is pretty
magical and something i haven't
experienced before
awesome and you're representing the uh
you're the european
the europe club exactly okay and what's
your role in the club
i'm a part of the leadership team
awesome
thank you uh joshua want to introduce
yourself
yes um hi everyone
thanks jessica i am together with
ori part of the leadership of the africa
business club i'm the president
um i have a co-president called eugene
who unfortunately could not make it
today
so welcome everyone before the gsb i was
in kanu nigeria
um and my favorite thing about the gsb
of course everyone is going to say the
people so i'll just add
um something else i'd say the inflection
that it forces upon yourself
even if you think you have it all
figured out i assure you stanford will
force you to
think it through all over again so i
really like that
it's beautifully said thank you and
finally mark
thank you jessica um my name is mark i'm
from germany as well
originally from a small town called
munster western part of germany but
lived in london in the uk
most recently before coming to the gsb
um i'm a co-president for the europe
club i'm working with jacob and the
leadership team over there
and my favorite thing at the gsb um
i have to agree with orient and jacob
about the people i think
i've never been in a community that is
on one hand
inspiring you but also challenge you to
really reach your goal and
take the next step um but on a more
broader level to take a step back i
think it's about the opportunities um
you really
have time to reflect you have time to
move into any kind of direction
you want to go into and i feel like this
kind of freedom
and a little bit to explore is something
that i really appreciate about the time
of year
awesome thank you all so to begin
i wanted to ask if you all could tell us
about the clubs you're representing
um what who's involved what students are
involved and what kinds of
events initiatives or programs does your
club organize
whoever wants to start
okay i can go so
um the africa
business club focuses
on those on creating
a community of this is the word
business or african business amongst
those
who appreciate africa's potential
and africa's nature and africa's people
we like to say that we promote
non-exploited business on the continent
because
um people have been doing business on
the continent for
centuries um but most of that kind of
the most of the business is not the kind
that we want to happen
so we i'm focused on promoting
non-exploitative
business we also focus on promoting
community between those
um who are from the continent and those
who want to learn more about the
continent
and that is as regards those here
on the gsb and so with that kind of
broad mandate
people who are involved in the club
range
from students at the gsb so african
students at the gsb
or non-african students of
african descent um at the gsb
and people who are also not
africans at all at the gsb and we're
also focusing a lot on getting people
from
other programs who are very interested
in business on the continent so whether
they want to start
businesses or whether they want to just
become um
you know investors or they just want to
learn more about it so
it's a pretty broad mandate and hence um
a broad um participant
um pool um i want to
maybe allow ori to sound in a little bit
before i talk about some of the events
um or
programs that we do
yeah thanks thanks joshua i think i
totally agree
there are such um there's so many
different kinds of people that join the
africa business club which makes it
um a really wonderful community to be a
part of people that have various
different connections to the continent
people that want to learn more and i
think that spirit
leads to the kinds of events that we
throw community building
speaker series all sorts so really
grateful to be part of this community
yes um and so maybe i can
um just list a few of the events that
we organize um pre-coffee times
we had a very definite set of events
we had um launches which we call the
next stop series with you know people
who had um started businesses on the
planet people who had invested on the
planet whether
a game of african descent of non-african
descent
trying to um trying to answer topical
questions like where do you start your
business should it be at home
or should it be a way um how do you get
funding and things like that
we had um an inspire series which
we were supposed to start last year with
um the seed which you'll get to know
about the focus on entrepreneurship in
emerging markets and that
brings very high ticket um speakers
to um talk about you know some of the
experiences breaking barriers
um investing on the continent government
on the continent
and our capstone um event is the
um africa business forum which is the
largest student run
and uh maybe even attended
um events on campus usually has as many
as
500 people and usually happens in
um spring so this is just a sample of
some of the activities that we organize
awesome thank you so much for that
description
should we do a hat for the euro club
yeah
please sure um i'm happy to start and
i'll let
jacob out um so who's involved in euro
club
um we're a leadership team of six
mba 2 students and we have about 120
members in our in our club so it's about
a quarter of the
of the students or like um of one
particular year
um i think our mission is really
three-fold i think we want to advance
the
cultural understanding of europe we want
to add to the social cohesiveness and we
also want to
provide some professional education um
so what do i mean by that i think
first on the cultural kind of awareness
part we want to make sure that we
take parts from europe um and bring it
to the gsb so we had
in the past we had italian dinners we
had german breakfasts we had
some kinds of celebrations we had like
an oktoberfest pre-drilled
it um and we also right now are
considering like online and virtual
events that we can
host to to you know um replace these
in-person events
i think secondly social we want to
create cohesiveness and identification
with
europe within the school and within the
um students
but also we want to foster connections
of current students with alarm speakers
but many people don't know there are
actually a lot of alarms working in
europe
the gcp is usually known for having a
lot of alums in the bay area but there
are a lot of people in europe who
love to be connected with current
students so we really try to foster
those relationships most recently we
hosted um
a tech panel for instance with people
who worked in
technology companies in europe
and one some of the big players um it
was really helpful for students to
build these kind of connections um and i
think third
we try to really give a professional
education
to our club members so for instance
we've not only seen
a lot of europeans trying to go back to
to europe after the gsb but we've also
increasingly
seen domestic or american students or
international students as a whole trying
to move to europe for at least some part
of their post-gsb
career so in the past there have been
workshops on how to recruit in europe
how to
what is the interview etiquette in
europe how to obtain a visa and what is
the
word authorization environment and we
plan to continue to do so
uh i'll stop here and let electric about
i think mark you summed it up really
well a couple of points i'd like to
highlight is is
for example one thing we've tried to try
to do is bring just some of the european
topics here so we've had some discussion
series in the past
and kind of kind of bringing in a
diverse diverse opinion around some
some of the topics that are discussed
here in the gsb and bringing kind of a
new lens to it
i think that's something that that stood
out to me and and on the other hand
just seeing how many people are in some
way connected interested in europe is
always really engaging and getting those
people connected right if it's an nba
one and nba 2
alumni and connecting those people and
bringing them together
because that's what the gsp is all about
it's all about the people you get to
know here and and spanning that network
as
efficiently as possible is what i see is
kind of the main main priority for the
club
in making sure that whoever is
interested and whoever we can help out
is making sure that there's that there's
an opportunity there
awesome thank you all so much um i'm
struck by and i'm really excited to hear
about the ways that these clubs
cultivate community and connection which
is really what this week is all about
and i'm curious about the ways that
your clubs have used the resources of
the gsb to
connect with communities and expand your
connections whether that's with
guest speakers whether that's with
alumni so could you tell us a little bit
about
how how your clubs have connected with
different resources and departments
at gsb to expand community and connect
with people
maybe maybe uh i'll i'll take the first
kind of
things like things that come to mind on
the one hand what we try to do is we try
to co-host events with other clubs here
at the gsp so for example if we're
talking about entrepreneurship in europe
we'll
co co-sponsor the event with the
entrepreneurship club if we're talking
about consulting in europe
we'll do with the consulting club so
bringing kind of different student clubs
together at
the gsb is really powerful and making
sure that people who are interested
actually see the events
and and that happens
um and then also working kind of with
alumni if they come to campus here
because there's some class reunion
that's obviously a great opportunity to
have to have an alumni speak i know we
had bill browder at the beginning of
last year
which was a really great event um and
what else comes to mind
and and generally alumni are just great
for for panelists that's kind of an
upside of of this whole zoom environment
is that it's much
it's much more common to jump on kind of
a a lunch session with somebody in
europe who's kind of in their
evening session as as all of you who are
who are dialing in europe at the moment
are kind of at their at their afternoon
already
um that's a great opportunity to get
people here and get them involved you
know if somebody founded a company in
italy or something normally
he maybe wouldn't come out fly out for
for a lunch session but we can
definitely have him zoom in so there's a
huge opportunity there at the moment
i think it was recently just to add to
this i think we've also
engaged very frequently with the
cmcu with the career management center
at the gsb
actually jacob and i will have a have a
call with them later this afternoon
to discuss recruiting strategies for
first and second year students in europe
and
basically brainstorm ideas how to create
even more opportunities for students to
make the move over to europe
yeah and from the africa business club
perspective i think a lot of the same
things apply
partnering with the cmc to highlight
career opportunities working with alumni
and taking advantage
of this virtual world for people to just
pop in but to add a more
a lighthearted thing um the gsb gives us
a lot of money for food
and so we and african food is great so
we come together
um pre-covered um in person to
just enjoy the food across the continent
but also virtually
um having lunches together to kind of
build community and learn more about
um the different cultural aspects across
the continent
you know already saying that just made
me hungry
so yes
um i definitely echo everything that
jacob mark and already have said and you
know
in addition we work together for example
with admissions because also something
that we care about is
um improving and increasing african
attendance
here at the gsb and even in at stanford
in general as many of you know
um some other schools maybe are closer
to the continent and so
um stanford um there's a big opportunity
for stanford to increase
its uh presence on the continent
um we work together for example with
seed because they focus a lot on
um emerging economies and they are very
wonderful with
a lot of the programs you know that they
have planned a lot of the entrepreneurs
that they've supported a lot of the
businesses
who sometimes are even looking for some
of the members of the club to assist
with projects and and call and finally i
just highlight
my tennessee program that is also
focused on you know getting more people
from the continent into the program and
we're trying to see how we can expand
and working with them
so um of course there are many more but
we
just shows you that the resources at the
gsb are always at our disposal
awesome thank you all um now i'm feeling
hungry too
um so thank you all for sort of walking
us through the nuts and bolts of your
organizations
i was also curious to hear about your
personal experiences with your
organizations as well
if you could share how you got involved
what is it that drew you to the
organization
and made you want to take a leadership
role i would love to hear
about your sort of personal journey to
and through
the organizations you're representing
okay maybe i can go first this time only
the abc can go first this time um
actually it was food that drew me in
um well during the the
orientation week a few people from
the club you know had reached out to
make us feel welcome just
um hi hello and of course after the
i think it was even before the academic
adjustment period had
ended we had i think a welcome event
um you know where everybody tries to
make us
feel welcome you know tell us um how we
can make this place a home away from
home so
i i think i was just sucked in by the
warmth and you know sometimes the
relative familiarity
um of hearing people who understand my
context talk about
this and i felt at least personally that
it was very helpful to me and if i could
make myself available to
do it for others then
why not so i think that's one of the
things that
stimulated my interest in taking up a
leadership
position another would be
that uh coming here i
i'm really passionate about africa some
would
call me an african you know yeah
many of these labels are cool and um i'm
personally from
nigeria which holds let's say
an important um position or distinction
in nigeria
and so coming here i had a thesis
that people like me and you know many
people like
us here our contribution to our
countries and our continent
would be very important in um you know
moving us from imagine economies to
um where it is that we exactly want to
be
and so i thought that bbc was a
wonderful platform
to try out that thesis and you know
connect with other people who
shared those same thoughts um with me so
i think
i'll um drop those two and see what
worry
what motivated ori to take up the
leadership position
yeah i think similarly so i um
was born in lagos nigeria my family's
from delta state um nigeria and being
nigerian is a very core part of
who i am and my experiences and and
i want to give back to the country and
the continent that
did so much for me and got me to where i
am today so
i think that was the impetus for me
wanting to be a part of the
afghan business club food also helped um
i member my favorite event that we did
last year was
at the very beginning we all um drove up
to san francisco to one of the new
um nigerian restaurants um because
they're they're few and far between
or over here in the bay um and it was
just a wonderful opportunity to be
connected to my classmates
and um and when i
decided to be part of leadership it was
based on the encouragement of joshua and
eugene but
um is an opportunity to help shape what
the future contributions of this club
can be for future classes and also for
um
how we can give back to the the diaspora
community here in the bay in the u.s and
also
abroad so really grateful for that
opportunity
you can hand it over to the europe club
i'll take this off um i think what drew
me is also kind of a sense of sense of
community as i arrived here you quickly
get to know a couple of people in the
euro club there's an intro event
and you have immediately some sort of
connection that you can reach out to and
i think
going forward europe is going to be some
part of my my my journey so
connecting with people in the area and
in the region is obviously really
helpful to that
um in terms of the leadership role i
felt like it was
my responsibility to to participate and
and shape that for the for the incoming
class so for example we organized these
one-on-one chats in the summer
as everybody was kind of really unsure
about the covet situation making sure
that everybody who you know all the
admits who were accepted here
felt welcome felt prepared could just
voice even the the simplest of questions
um and and creating that sense of
community is is my
my main priority for the people who are
here and and making sure everybody feels
like like stanford is a home and the gsb
is their home
yeah i'll i'll act for everything at
jacob's side i think
for me personally there were two factors
that i want to highlight
one um i feel like some regional groups
have a very strong identification of the
gsb
with where they're coming from and i
feel like with the
with especially people coming from
europe that identification
does more happen on a country level but
not on a continent level and
we felt that given that there are so
many people from europe around it would
be great to just create a little bit
more identification
with the continent um and i think too
although i want to spend some time after
the gsb
in in the us i really want to go back to
europe in the long run
and basically helping set structures in
place and
helping create connections between
students and alums is really the one
thing that
excited me especially as i think about
my post gsb
time some years down the road
awesome thank you all so much it's it's
clear that community is really important
to all of you and to your organizations
and i think ori kind of touched on this
a little bit already but i'd be curious
to hear some more of those stories like
what is one of your
favorite memories um from your time with
the club
and ori feel free to share another one i
definitely feel like i'm going to need
to grab myself a snack
after this panel hearing about all of
the food adventures but
yeah what's a what's a favorite memory
that you all have had during your time
with these clubs
okay um of course it involves food
by now you can tell it's a recurring
theme
but i'd say the nigerian independence
day
um last year so when i was on mba one
you know some of the mba twos tools
creator invited us to their pass down
and we had amazing food
spent an amazing time playing um games
and
literally just um reconnecting with
the continent from so far away it's
music um it's art
it's movies you know some of the jokes
some of the slangs
and by the until i left that house i
literally thought i was at home
in nigeria i i think
anytime i think upon that day i still
smile
i can i can add next to my favorite
memories i think coincidentally they
also revolve around food
so there was a small group dinner series
and
in the fourth quarter of winter quarter
last year where
members from the europe club could just
sign up with
mba two um group dinner
leaders it was really a setting of six
or seven
gsb students across classes but with
this common connection of
coming from europe or wanting to go to
europe um and it was just like a really
lovely evening we spent together and had
great conversations that revolved about
the europe club but also
about gsb life in general so i think
that was one of my highlights um
and a second one just very personally um
one of the mba two student leaders one
year ago organized a german breakfast
back in the day which i didn't have for
for ages jacob was there as well um and
we just spent
i think a sunday morning together with a
few people maybe 20.
um and basically shared our tradition in
shadow culture and that was really
a very rewarding experience for me
to go next uh i think for me it was
those early moments when i came to gsb
and immediately had a couple of people i
could reach out to i could
you know get ask all those stupid
questions you don't know who to ask
and and how incredibly helpful they were
in terms of that
in terms of just you know orienting
yourself around campus and
you know course selection and all that
all that good stuff
and that was extremely helpful um
i think that's that definitely stands
out and i think secondly actually
highlight has been being part of
leadership this year um
so that's been what's been really good
and really fun getting to know
the the leadership team and working
together on making sure there's great
events and we engage the community
and that's been extremely rewarding
i guess i could add another story um i
i remember sometime last year we had had
one of the next up series attendees come
and
and and admit something that's very
special about the abc
community is that the conversations
don't just stop in that room
and we were able to continue the
conversations um
in my room actually it's still over food
i made jollof rice and plantain
and uh eugene and people from kenya
ghana ghana and nigeria were all in my
room we were discussing
you know our passions for the continent
and we all come from different
backgrounds some have spent significant
time
in their different respective countries
some less so and so being able to have
that conversation
um together was just really special for
for me awesome thank you all so much for
your stories and i i
hope your stories are helpful for all of
the attendees on the line for us
um jacob you had mentioned how
helpful it was to have that opportunity
to ask people all of those
quote unquote stupid questions um upon
arriving on campus and i'm just
wondering
sort of going beyond the organizations
you're representing today
knowing that we have so many folks on
the line who
have maybe never been to campus before
are calling in from
all over the world what's something that
surprised you about the gsb
or maybe something you wish you had
known about the gsb prior to
the application process or prior to
arriving on campus
i may not be the best person to answer
this question because i knew very very
little about the program i like actively
didn't know too much
the only thing i knew is that i knew a
couple of alumni who did the pro
you know who did this in the 90s in the
80s and the way they talked
about it 30 years out was so
enthusiastic that i thought i
and i these are people i really value so
i was sure it was going to be an
incredible experience and it was just
kind of
the opportunity i got in here i'm just
going to enjoy the ride and not
not stress too much about the details so
uh i think one thing i didn't appreciate
before coming
is um how much this is a reflective
exercise as much as learning exercise
so it's much more about learning about
yourself i think that is one thing
kind of one angle i previously hadn't
really appreciated it
i'll add i'll um again can only after
what jacob said i think
two aspects that stood out for me is one
what really surprised me is the
humility of the people um it
i mean obviously gcp attracts very
interesting candidates from all walks of
life but um i
yet have to come across um a person in
our class that is really
like not humble and doesn't really um
you know act in ways that are very open
to connect and open to share his or her
expertise
so i think that was one of the most
pleasantly surprising factors
um one thing i wish i had known is
how much of a choose your own adventure
it is it's really it really comes
down to you what you want to put your
focus on and you can go through these
two years and
study very hard for every class you can
go through this two years and
try to meet everyone in your class you
can try to
spend two years recruiting and you can
do pretty much everywhere in between but
it's really about you
what you want to put your focus on your
priorities in
and i think that's something that i
didn't really realize
yeah what mark and jacob have said uh
resonates so much with me um
i can add one or two
i'd say what has surprised me the most
about the jsb
how much i didn't know coming here
if i were to give a simple example i'd
say that in my mind
i had mapped business out in my head
along particular verticals and my
thought was oh it's like this it's like
this is like
i've had to unlearn that totally and
relearn shall we say a new um paradigm
and just as i thought
that oh i had figured it out i realized
that oh it's ever changing
and so i have to allow this small
confidence interval for change
so um just and to max point about how
many how people here are humble it's
it's really just
about how in tune they are with how much
they
need to continue learning on a daily
basis to remain relevant and to become
leaders that can actually change
organizations and change the world
so that that has been very surprising
what i wished i knew i wish i knew how
athletic
people and outdoorsy people were
here you know i might have picked up a
hobby gotten in shape it's literally
like waiting for someone
going to the beach you know people
people um
definitely balance um health concerns
with you know academic consent and and
just as they're trying to develop their
minds they're also trying to
um you know develop themselves
holistically physically and
and otherwise and and that has been
really
um refreshing you won't see a
portability at the gsb
i'll show you
um i i didn't think i could be surprised
by the gsb because i had come here un
for undergrad so i feel like i knew
stanford i knew
the thing um but uh something
i wish i'd known is that while it's
important to be focused i think the two
years fly by
like that just can't believe we're
already at this point
um it's important to leave room for
serendipity
because i think it's those moments where
you didn't expect something to happen
the meeting with someone from across
campus or
the class that you weren't sure was
really aligned with what you wanted to
do
but had an aha moment in that and taking
a little bit of a risk
that i think you get some of the most
special magical moments
here
awesome thank you all so much for
sharing so at this time
in the session we're going to shift
towards taking some questions from
our attendees so for our attendees who
joined
late feel free to submit your questions
in the q a box for our panelists
we're very very grateful for your
questions
so there's a theme of questions from our
attendees around
alumni can you all talk a little bit
about the alumni networks
in europe and in africa
okay i can go for
the abc and then oricon feel free to add
in it
there's anything i left out i'd say that
the
alumni network from africa is
amazing um it's
it's not just deep it's connected in
such a way
as to for you to feel like you're all in
the same space
so it's while you can have access to a
very wide network
and the degrees of separation and maybe
the process that you need to go through
to bridge those gaps
can sometimes make it feel like it's
adverse work
here everybody feels like they're just
one degree of separation away
and so that the network is very close
and the network
doesn't just include africans it
includes those
who have walked on the continent
invested on the continent from other
places because i'm sure as you very well
know there are many non-africans that
share our passion for
um for africa and
um the networks are also in terms of
achievements
i'd say that they are matched you have
people with
ideas that have changed the world that
are currently changing the world
and um for example i'll give you a
specific
example our inspire speaker series that
we're trying to organize
we decided we wanted um you know
somebody who
when when we mentioned in the forum they
were like no it's impossible
um to bring that person now they're just
too busy but
just spoke to someone who just graduated
and he was like oh definitely i spoke
with him yesterday just let me text him
and see so that's how um
uh you know productive that network is
so
i don't know if already has anything to
add
yeah i 100 agree i think just a couple
examples of how that manifests are
we have this um whatsapp group that has
maybe the last six years
of um africa business club alumni
on it and anyone you want to speak to
any
startup you think you've heard about in
some country someone knows that person
and there is just a deep desire to
support each other
um and help people achieve their career
dreams
and i think because of the strength of
the alumni network it's
exactly why we're able to get such
amazing speakers um and
people are just always willing to to
speak with you and come to our events
still to this day
one of the favorite event i spoke about
we had alumni there too
um that just wanted to pop in and stay
connected so i think it's a very strong
community
all over the continent and even in in
europe and all over the world so
it's a very powerful resource
i'll add to that from the euro club
perspective so we have a whatsapp group
as well
which is very active especially when it
comes to uh logistical questions so
whenever there's a question of
who knows an immigration lawyer and
who knows how to get a visa while being
in country xyz um that's really where
i think the value of this whatsapp group
and just being connected
on such a short dial with the alums
really comes to life
um i think secondly there's there are a
lot of people at the gsb
who are trying to trying to build
stronger networks in europe so we work
very closely friends with the cmc
i was part of a group who um planned the
planet study trip
to europe and we basically um pulled in
all resources from europe club to
deteriorate management center to
basically structure a program
that targeted specifically building alum
connections in europe
um and i can just speak for for the uk
and germany
um the alum um community over there is
very active
so there are like frequent receptions i
think jacob attended one of these in
germany back in the days um where really
alums
from back to the 80s or 90s
invite people and admits to to the house
and have a chat with them
i attended such a chat in london back in
the days and was really a great
opportunity
to connect with alarms and build
credentials across radiation years
just to add some color i think what
always stands out to me is how
how personal these connections are like
for example we had an
admit event with an 86 of um who's a
board member of one of germany's largest
companies and you think this would be a
some formal event um and it ended up
being him
grilling barbecuing in his backyard with
just a group of 20 people
extremely personal very very interested
in what we're doing and what we're up to
and
and helping us out and and challenging
us so i think that
that really differentiates the alumni
network it's not only a professional
group of people
you know sitting down and talking about
about career or business whatever this
is really about building that
personal connection and getting to know
somebody as a human being
rather than as just somebody in your
network and in your roller decks
awesome thank you all sounds like our
alumni are just as hungry as we are
ready to grab a plate and connect with
current students
another great question from one of our
attendees
um bomi writes i imagine studies take up
a lot of time and are very challenging
how does joining a club complement your
studies more than it distracts or takes
up your time and how do you find a
balance
between your studies and
extracurriculars
i didn't speak to that um and i think
i'll
i can elaborate a little bit more on the
point that i mentioned earlier which is
that it's pretty much like you choose
your own adventure um
program over here um obviously it's an
academic program and you need to devote
sufficient time to to your studies but
there's also
there's always a certain degree how much
effort or how much time you put into
the classes so you know sometimes you
want to
get great grades and you spend an extra
hour finishing up an essay
sometimes you feel that this particular
class is not one of your focus areas so
you might
um try to shortcut a little bit and and
that's fine as well i think at the end
of the day
studies um hardly take up our entire
days at any given point in time
you know coleslaw can vary over the
years but over the quarters but at the
end of the day
i feel like hardly anybody spends his
entire day
on academics so i feel like the clubs
don't um cannibalize time you could
spend on class time um i feel on the
other hand it rather complements it
as it gives you a kind of peer group of
people who are coming from the same
background who might
have similar ways of thinking and you
can just easily reach out to them and
connect on on things you learned in
class and on the other hand
um you might have come across somebody
that you find incredibly inspiring who's
a guest speaker
in your in your class who comes from
europe comes from africa who comes from
any part of the world
and um those clubs might be able to help
you to build that connection to that
particular person or to give you
introductions in a specific field so
i in my point of view um that's my very
very individual point of view i feel
like the club's only compliment and i
don't feel
like my involvement in euro club neither
as a member last year nor as a
leadership person this year
um does take away too much time from
from the studies
okay i might add to that
i i agree totally with everything mark
has said i think it actually complements
your studies
and i think that leadership is often a
balance between
multitasking with empathy and
ruthless prioritization
and since we're here in the mba to
advance our course as leaders and learn
how to be leaders this is literally just
a practice test and a practice test
wherein code failure doesn't come with
very huge consequences so this is a safe
space for you to try out these skills
and become a leader
and so to that um and
you find people in five clubs and they
are at the top of the class and there
are people in
two clubs and they are very okay with
both
the academic and their social experience
so
again to mark's point it's it's it's a
self-directed agenda
um i can add that our leadership teams
are usually pretty big
and so people can help take off
weight on you if things are particularly
heavy
for a certain week and vice versa and so
i think there's a lot of balance that
way by sharing the burden
um and i do think being part of
leadership
um and being part of these clubs can
complement your studies i had
um i had to write a paper on this
company named silco watch space in kenya
and i knew that someone knew this
founder because i was part of the abc
club and were able to talk to them and
get like i think a great paper
because of it so i think they're like
very tactical perks but
uh because of what we talked about
earlier about people at the gsb just
being so kind and
welcoming and helpful that um your
members of your leadership team can help
you
when when the load is particularly heavy
yeah i think i have nothing to add you
all said it perfectly
thank you all we have another great
question from mikhail
who writes were there any cultural
differences that you struggled with in
stanford specifically
or in california in general like how to
start a conversation
how to stay online things like that or
anything else
and if there were any cultural
differences that you struggled with how
did you
manage or overcome them
i can go
um i'm a little bit of a philosopher
and so and so i
i generally believe that the pathway
to whatever destination it is that we
um get to is necessarily going to have
turns obstacles potholes and corn that
each and every one of those
things adds extra to the experience and
so
i have savored those differences
actually and learned from them and i
find out that
sometimes what you learn from those
differences are
um the actually transferable skills when
it comes to things like managing upwards
in the workplace or managing a very
diverse workforce or things like that
and um so personally i'd say i've
learned
mostly by observation seeing how other
people from other contexts to it
but sometimes it's actually just been
asking a blunt question and saying
hey i realized that we do things
differently where i come from
i knew people do things in this way
um can you please explain the rationale
um
and then you create some blended
um solution for yourself because that's
the beauty of all of this
i think because california is so
welcoming and specifically the gsb
you're not expected to do it
in a particular we expected to do it
your way
as long as um there's regard for
community
and other people's feelings and how
um the you know your your actions land
on others so um
i i'd say that it's still a work in
progress
and maybe the two years of an mba is
actually too short for you to be able to
fully overcome all of all of these
things but actually think it's
part of the mba experience that you will
enjoy
as an international student because many
people would also ask you hey
i see you guys do things in a different
way
i'm actually enamored with it can you
tell me about it so
it's a little bit of give and take
anybody else want to chime in on this
question
yeah i think i totally agree with josh
there's a couple of like ground norms
that are established pretty quickly at
the gsb and then within that it's really
about
an individual and how you show up as an
individual and that that matters most
and
this is an environment where you get to
know each other as individuals rather
than as you know
whatever stereotypes you have so i think
it's actually an incredible opportunity
to bridge those kind of cultural gaps
that sometimes may exist
yeah i think one aspect that i will add
is
i feel like the gsb is a lot about
self-disclosure
i think it's about making yourself known
and having other people know you
um and i think that's something that i
might be
too generalizing here but i feel like in
in the german culture where i grew up
that is not as much of a focus point in
interpersonal dynamics as it is
um maybe in the us and california at the
gsb in particular i don't know where
when the funnel is really um active but
i feel like the level of self-disclosure
and like how
vulnerable you show yourself to each
other
um is really something that was somewhat
new to me at the same time
was the kind of foundation for a lot of
very meaningful
relationships and friendships
awesome thank you all we have another
great question
from sabrina who writes what do you feel
that the impact of the african europe
clubs has been
on gsb's campus um sabrina
adds that she would also love to hear
what you all are most excited about for
the africa
and europe clubs in regard to their
futures
for the africa business club i think i
mentioned during the introduction that
we organized
um as an independent event because of
some logistical
um concerns the
stanford africa business forum which is
the largest africa run
um student event
sorry largest student-run event on
campus
and during that time the gsb
literally gives us the entire campus
to make use of you know the facilities
the faculty are very helpful
um the staff on the back end
everything um and so this has
shall we say created a a bit of
uh deeper knowledge a deeper interest in
african issues
amongst both staff and um
people who otherwise might not might
just meet an african
every other month or every year you know
um stuff like that so i'd say that in
that respect the adc has had a huge
influence here secondly
i i think that there's a greater
engagement
with african issues from the diversity
perspective
um so for example with the nsa's
protests in nigeria the other day
um everybody who
had a nigerian address attached to them
or maybe the identity got an email from
why does stanford school not even just
just be saying
hey we understand this must be a
stressful time you know
things like that but what i heard from
the back end or from the back side
is that um a lot of it had to do
with you know conversations with the gsb
um uh leadership or
gsb faculty so it means that
our effect has not just been on the jsv
it has also extended as far as
um stanford um
i would also say that because
we have created a conduit of african
food here on campus
and now everybody can call the lady who
supplies
um the food there's a renaissance of
african food around campus so before
long you might go to a canteen here
and the only kind of rice you'll be able
to buy is jello fries
so
and i can quickly chime in on the second
part of what i'm really excited about
for the african business club um i think
eugene and josh have done such a great
job
um pushing forward cross-campus
engagement uh not only at stanford
between different schools like the law
school and med school people that are
interested in
africa but also other schools like
berkeley and are just next door or given
the virtual world
uh just other schools around the us and
i think that's a really
beautiful opportunity to build community
that's this burst and so i'm really
excited about that
yeah i think in terms of in terms of
impact it is around the goals that we
stated you know it's um
it's social it's getting people together
on the social level get
get get people connected it's making
sure
people who are interested in working in
europe have the resources have to have
the capabilities feel ready
to to jump into the job search there and
um
and yeah and then i think thirdly
probably around admissions making sure
that applicants are there and that
people who are accepted here or
feel welcome and you know who know who
to reach out to
and um and get connected with it's kind
of the impact we we try and have
and there's still so much so much we
want to do on all three levels so that's
what i'm excited about i'm excited to
get more europeans here i'm excited to
get more people to work in europe
and i'm excited to create a stronger
sense of community of everybody who's in
any way
interested or connected to europe and
make sure you know people know each
other and
not only know each other on a
superficial level for that kind of as i
was saying before for the rolodex but
actually get to know each other
as as a person
yeah i'll close out with saying in terms
of impact
um there has been this program over the
summer
that um basically matched up people from
the europe club leadership
with admits who had questions about the
gsb
over the summer and um we we all had
this jetson leadership team
and just like connecting with the folks
that i spoke to back then
it seemed like that these touch points
have been incredibly helpful for them so
i think we just want to
keep keep being available as a resource
to provide insights both for people who
want to come here but also for people
who are here
um what i'm most excited about um
i feel like probably
one aspect is a professional aspect
there have been a few people from
our class who are domestic american
students who
got really excited about the prospect of
living in europe
and i feel like seeing them and hearing
the feedback that basically our sessions
provided helpful insights to them
it was really rewarding and i feel like
we want to continue to do that
awesome thank you all so much so i see
we're coming up to the top of the hour
we have one final question
i want to thank our attendees for all of
the really really thoughtful questions
they've submitted
if you have any outstanding questions
please feel free to reach out to our
office
or attend more of the diversity and
leadership events going on this week
to learn more about student experiences
at the gsb
um you'll also see a poll pop up so if
you could
please fill out the poll so we can
continue improving
oh my apologies there is no poll on this
event
but if you have any additional questions
please feel free to reach out to us
our final question for this session is
looking back if you could go back in
time what advice would you give yourself
as you were getting ready for business
school
i'll go fast again um
i would say choose tomfood
okay seriously um
[Music]
i think that um
the advice i'd give myself is to come
more open-minded um
i came here with the thesis about what
exactly i wanted
and it changed
maybe like after four or five weeks i
can see a scenario where if i had been
more open-minded earlier
um i might even have absorbed a lot more
than i did
um before i figured out that i was doing
it the wrong way and yes
um already made the point earlier that
you you need to be focused
about the range of things that you want
to get out of the business school
experience because this is like
candyland
and you can get pushed in a million
different directions
but um still having that
receptiveness to the many aha moments
that can occur in many different
settings
to set you down the path that maybe you
were made for
and i i i think that's what i tell
myself
for me uh if i could go back to myself
pre gsb i would take more time off
um i think i've never been as busy as i
have been at the gsd
and it's it's a wonderful thing because
you're seeing people you're
going to meetings you're meeting like
great speakers and all that stuff
but it is exhausting too and
so take some time take care of yourself
before you jump into this
whirlwind experience
i think similarly to ori um get ready
just to
stretch yourself so whatever you need to
to get ready for the for this experience
i think i think take the time and get
into the right
headspace that once you're here uh
you're you're ready to learn to engage
in
and bring your best self
yeah i'll like everything that has been
said i think in addition
i think it helps to come in with a
hypothesis of what you want to do
during the two years and after the gsb
at the same time i
emphasize or it resonates a lot when i
never said that um you should let give
yourselves
the kind of room for serendipity um i
think the gsp can be a rocket ship that
takes you
on the career you never even thought was
possible it can be a playground where
you try a few things and
something is worth some things don't but
ultimately it seems like
most if not all of the alums have found
this experience incredibly
rewarding no matter what their journey
has been so um
don't like come in with some goals but
don't get too focused on them and let
basically let yourself be inspired by
the experience and by the classmates
that you come across
awesome thank you all so much for
sharing your experiences with us today
and thank you so much to our
attendees for joining us as we wrap up
as i said before feel free to reach out
to us if you have more questions
attend more of our diversity and
leadership events or continue your
journey at mystanford.mba
thank you so much for joining us today
and i hope everyone has a great rest of
your day